Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Dominic
Preuss, and I'm
very excited to be here
today at Google I/O talking
about the Google Cloud Platform.
I'm the product lead for
Google's storage and database
products on the
Google Cloud Platform.
As many of you know,
data is everything,
and it's at the core of
everything that Google does.
Whether it be the original
BackRub algorithm or some
of the machine learning
things you saw in the keynote
yesterday from Sundar, it really
is the basis of everything
we do at Google.
So what we're trying to do
is provide that platform
that is the best place for
you to bring your data to be
able to do similar
things to what
Google's been doing internally.
The way that we
want to achieve this
is by building a fully
integrated data platform
that is converged and makes
it as easy as possible
for you get your data into the
system, move it, process it,
and enrich it, and then
derive value from it.
We don't want you to worry
about where your data ends up
or where you decide
to store your data.
We want to make sure that
data is never in a silo
and that it's easy to
do what you need to do
with it to complete your task.
So to achieve this
vision, we've built
a suite of storage
and database products
for customers to bring
their data into the system.
This will give us a
little bit of a level set
before I dig into some of
the later parts of the talk.
The goal of this
talk is threefold.
It's to give you an overview
of our storage products.
It's to give you a couple of
simple reference architectures
to give you an idea of how
you might build a solution.
And then it's to give
you a couple of examples
of customers that are currently
doing this on Google Cloud
Platform.
So in this portfolio,
we'll start all the way
at the object store.
So Google Cloud Storage
is our object store.
This is where you put your
objects, videos, or data
that you're trying to process
via different products
in the platform.
It's used for media serving
as well as a collection
point for data before you run
your data processing pipelines.
What's interesting about
Google Cloud Storage that's
fundamentally different
from other offerings
is that it is
inherently multi-region.
So when you put an object
into the object storage
using our Standard
class, your data
is actually replicated
across multiple regions.
So it gives you a higher level
of availability and ability
to serve that data back
out to your customers.
Google Cloud Storage comes with
three different storage classes
to match your user need.
The first one that I
mentioned already is Standard.
The second one is Durable
Reduced Availability.
And what that means is if
you're willing to accept
slightly lower availability,
we'll give you a better price.
And then our third
one that we introduced
in the middle of last
year is Nearline,
which basically allows you, for
$0.01 per gigabyte per month,
to store your data in the same
interface and the same product
that would store your more
frequently accessed data.
Moving onto the
relational side, Cloud SQL
is our managed RDBMS, Relational
Database Management System
service.
So this is where you can go
to get a fully managed MySQL
database with high availability
and pay as you go semantics,
just like you would if you
were rolling it on your own.
But instead of you worrying
about the problems,
you can let Google site
reliability engineers
worry about those for you.
These are really good if
you're-- Cloud SQL is great
if you're building on a
framework or have a piece
of software that requires a
specific piece of software,
like MySQL, and really makes
it easy for you to get up
and running with almost no work.
If you want to go
down the NoSQL path,
we have two different offerings.
One is Cloud Datastore.
Cloud Datastore is our
application database
that allows you
to, from scratch,
just start storing data.
There's no requirements
or defining a schema.
You don't have to
provision size.
All you do is start storing your
data in an unstructured way.
We then make it as
easy as possible
for you to get
access to that data
and allow you to
scale up to any level.
We see this very much used in
the mobile and web applications
as the default place
that people go,
especially if they're
building applications
on Google App Engine.
Our other NoSQL database
is Cloud Bigtable.
So we published the Bigtable
white paper many years ago
and spawned a lot
of the work that's
being done in the NoSQL world.
We've now taken that
internal Bigtable service
and externalized it as
a service for customers
with a HBase-compatible
client library.
So what this allows you to do
is to take your HBase and some
of your Cassandra workloads,
and bring them over and start
serving them off of
Cloud Bigtable in a fully
managed way.
You no longer have to
manage your clusters,
your HBase clusters.
You can just let Google
manage those for you.
This is very frequently used
in heavy read/write workloads.
So we see this in Internet
of Things workloads,
collecting sensor data,
time series databases,
and anything that
has high throughput
and needs low latency reads.
Our last one is for caching.
So if you have an
application in App Engine
that you need a
caching layer, we
provide a fully managed
Memcache service.
So again, this allows
you to just use Memcache
without having to worry about
how many nodes is it on,
how much storage do you have,
how much memory do you have
on the node to be able to fit
all of your keys, what happens
when your keys if you
have to reboot your node.
All those things are handled for
you in a fully managed service.
So now we'll start talking
about reference architectures.
And I'm going to
start with-- I'm
going to do all of these
in two different ways.
We're going to start
with the NoSQL world,
and then we'll do RDBMS,
and then we'll do NoSQL.
I don't want to start a
religious debate about which
is better, so I'm just
going to cover both.
If you are working in
the relational database
world, the quickest
way to get up
and running from your
concept of your idea
to a megabyte of data, is
either from your web application
or from the web browser
client or the mobile client,
to build your application,
deploy it on Compute Engine,
and then store your
structured data
in Cloud SQL and your
unstructured data
in Cloud Storage.
So this way you can
put all of your data
that's being generated
off of your framework,
whether it be Rails
or Django or any
of the other popular
frameworks, and then you
can put your static
data in Cloud Storage.
Basically, it's a couple of
clicks to get these things up
and running, and
then you can get--
and start serving
your prototype out
to a small number of people.
Now, if you wanted to do
the same thing with NoSQL,
the way that we do
this is those same web
and mobile
applications or clients
that are speaking
to App Engine, which
then speaks to Cloud Datastore.
Now, the thing that
we announced yesterday
that we're very excited about
is adding Firebase support
for Google Cloud Storage.
So now those static
files and you're
saving, either from your
JavaScript web applications
or your mobile
applications, can be
put into Google Cloud Storage
via the Firebase set of client
libraries.
If you were doing this yourself,
you'd write a few lines of code
in App Engine to be able to
serve that information out,
and that data would be
stored in Datastore for you.
Again, it's replicated,
highly available,
and allows you to start
taking your prototype out
to a larger number of people.
All right.
So you've got your
prototype, and you've
shown it to a few people,
and people like it.
So now, how do you push
this into production
so you can start to support
a real number of users?
The way that we do this is,
we take those same web clients
and point them at Google
Cloud Load Balancing.
Google offers a global
load balancing solution.
Again, very different than other
things that are on the market.
And then you would, behind that,
put one or many Compute Engine
virtual machines to actually
host your application.
So you would actually
be hosting your code
and serving that code
out of those VMs.
Again, you're serving
your data into Cloud SQL.
You can have a high availability
version of Cloud SQL
so that you have
high availability
and never lose your data, and
it's a single-click to do that.
And again, you're storing
your data in Cloud Storage.
So you haven't actually
changed anything.
You're using the
same set of products,
but you're just provisioning
them slightly differently
to make sure that you'll
scale up to level of load
that you have.
Now, if we go back
to the NoSQL path,
you can see that
this is suspiciously
like our last slide.
And again, you have
your web clients
in your mobile applications
talking to App Engine
or Firebase, and then storing
their data in Cloud Datastore
and Cloud Storage.
The beauty of going
down this path
is that you can scale from
basically zero and your concept
all the way up to terabytes
of data, and all of that
happens completely without
any intervention on your side.
You just keep
throwing data at it
and we'll just keep
consuming the data.
Whether it be in Datastore
or Cloud Storage,
it's a per consumption basis.
There's no provisioning.
You just throw data at it and
we'll go ahead and store it.
Great.
So now we've got this
product on the market.
It's in the App Store.
It's doing amazingly well.
App's getting slow.
We need to really
scale this out.
How do we support
millions of users?
So the way that
you would do this
is, if you're going down the
relational database model,
is take your web and mobile
clients-- speaking to the Cloud
Load Balancer, again, no
changes are needed on the load
balancer-- and
then you would just
be adding additional
numbers of compute engines.
Now, you can use things
like instance groups
and some of the other
features as well.
But to keep it
simple, we'll just
say that there's a number
of VMs necessary to serve
your application, and
then all of those VMs
and those applications are
speaking back to Cloud SQL.
Now, the one thing we've
done differently in Cloud SQL
is we've added read replicas.
So within Cloud SQL,
you can, with one click,
add read replicas to basically
scale out your read loads.
So basically all of your
reads in your application
would go to the read replicas,
and then you would just
send your rights to the master.
This allows you to continue
to scale on top of Cloud SQL
without having to do anything
other than add read replicas
and potentially change
the size of the VM
that's hosting your database.
The other thing that's
very-- is great about the way
that we've set up Compute Engine
is that it's very easy for you
to add capacity.
So if you attach a certain
number of persistent disks,
which is our block storage
solution, to those VMs that you
need to add capacity,
you can just
increase the size of the
volumes without having
to restart the machines.
We call it hot
grow, and it's a way
for people to add capacity
to their applications
without having any downtime.
So now I want to start
adding in some customers,
just to give you a
little bit of context
of how people are using these.
So Ocado is a UK
e-commerce provider.
They basically use
Cloud SQL as a way
to not have to worry about
managing their MySQL instances.
They allow Google
to do that for them
and they focus on building
their applications.
Applications that are very
transactionally sensitive,
whether it be payments or if you
have data that it has to always
be consistent, a
lot of those tend
to go down the Cloud SQL path.
And so e-commerce
and that vertical
tends to be very
popular with Cloud SQL.
Now, if we go back
to the NoSQL path,
again, this looks suspiciously
like our prior slide.
Because to go from
literally concept
up to terabytes of
data, nothing has
to change in terms
of your architecture.
As you add more
and more clients,
both Firebase and App
Engine will scale up
to serve those
requests, and that data
goes into Cloud Datastore
or into Cloud Storage
and there's no change necessary.
You can throw as much
traffic at it as you want
and they'll just scale
up to meet your needs.
This is the promise of the
platform, where we can just
respond to the amount of
demand that you're giving us,
and you don't have to worry
about prepaying for capacity.
You don't have to worry about
what the pricing does to you.
You know that if
you use the product,
we'll give you your sustained
use discounts on the VMs,
and you'll only pay for the data
that you use in the database.
So a good example of
going down this NoSQL path
is Khan Academy.
So Khan Academy uses Google
App Engine with Datastore.
And we're basically able
to scale from a small idea
up to a major website
without having
to make any architectural
changes to the way
that they build
their applications.
The goal of all these
things is really
to allow developers to focus
on writing code and not
managing their services.
So we're trying to
basically increase
the velocity of
development to the maximum
by removing anything that
isn't delivering value
to your end users.
So now we start to get into
some interesting areas.
So now we're going past
a terabyte of data.
And areas where we start to
see large amounts of data
is really in the data
aggregation space.
So there's a number
of different ways
that you might be
collecting data.
You might have a mobile
client application
which is speaking back
to Cloud Endpoints.
So Cloud Endpoints is
our hosted API endpoints
that allows you to offload
all the management of your API
to Google managed services.
And then the data that's
coming in from those endpoints
can be written into the
Cloud Bigtable which
we talked about earlier.
Another way is doing the
same thing with the web.
You have a web application.
You're collecting a bunch
of stats, time series data
that you need to push back
to the Compute Engine, which
then gets collected
in Cloud Datastore.
Again, you're just pushing
data into Cloud Datastore.
You're not worrying
about provisioning.
about, do you have
enough disk in the cluster.
All you're doing is pushing
data into Cloud Datastore.
And the third one is
the one that we're
seeing over and over again,
and one of the things
that I'm most excited about.
We keep seeing, over and over
again, people bringing us
really interesting
data pipelines
and ways of aggravating and
taking value of their data.
So a good example of
this is sensor data.
So if you have
millions of sensors
out there that are
collecting data every minute,
10 minutes, hour, they have
to send all that data back
to a single place.
What we do is we've seen people
using Cloud Pub/Sub, which
is our messaging queue product.
It's a global product.
It's not zonal.
So wherever your sensors
are in the world,
you can just push your
data into Pub/Sub.
And then using Cloud
Dataflow to then
process that data, either
in a batch or stream mode,
to push that data
into Cloud Bigtable.
And now we really
are seeing people
start to operate the same way
that Google does internally.
So internally, we use
Pub/Sub for messaging.
We use Dataflow, usually in
stream mode and not batch mode,
to then push all this
data into Cloud Bigtable.
You're now starting to see
people really implement
their data pipelines and their
data collection the same way
that we do inside Google,
and it's very exciting.
One of the things
that we did recently
that I'm very excited
about was a collaboration
that we did with FIS that
basically they went and took
and created 25 billion
synthetic market transactions
and were able to
process them in an hour.
And so they were
basically able to push
from putting data into
Google Cloud Storage,
processing with Dataflow,
putting it into Bigtable.
They were able to process
those 25 billion transactions
in under an hour.
And at peak, they were pushing
34 million reads a second
and 22 million writes a second
using 3,500 nodes of Bigtable.
So they were able to
do that without having
to buy hardware, provision it.
We worked with them
to make sure that we
had the capacity on hand
for them to run the test,
and then they were
able to execute that.
And it's something that we're
seeing over and over again,
that these companies
aren't able to run
at these levels of scale.
Because of just a
procurement cycle
that would be necessary
to acquire the hardware
to run a test of
this size, we were
able to spin up in
a couple of weeks.
So now we've gotten up
to a petabyte of data.
But it wouldn't be
Google if we didn't
talk about exabytes of data.
So how do you go from
having a petabyte of data
into an exabyte of data?
And where we start to see
this type of volume of data
is really in the
archival workload.
So we've got a couple
of ways for people
to ingest data
into our platform.
So one way to do this is
Google Cloud Transfer Service.
So we offer a product
that will allow
you to grab your data, either
from another Google Cloud
Storage bucket or
from Amazon S3,
and transfer that data
into Google Cloud Storage.
We will do this on a schedule.
If there are failures, we
will retry and make sure
that all the data gets over.
And we'll optimize and paralyze
the transfer to make sure
that we do it as
quickly as possible.
Another area that we're
seeing a lot of adoption,
especially from our
enterprise customers,
is in the storage
appliance space.
So we have gone out and worked
with a number of the storage
appliance companies
to partner with them
to create integrations
for Google Cloud Storage.
So companies like EMC,
NetApp, Veritas, Convault.
And the idea here is that these
customers have several 1, 2, 3,
10, 100 petabytes of data that
they've been sitting in a data
store that they're paying to
buy disks to maintain this data.
And so now, instead of
storing this on a capex basis
where they have to
buy these disks,
they can transfer it all into
Google Cloud Storage using
the same storage appliance
that they use today,
and back all that data
up into the cloud.
And they've gone from a
capex model, where they're
paying for actual
disks that they
have to be buying and storage
arrays, to a pure opex
model where they're purely
paying on a consumption
basis for storing that data.
We've helped companies
save millions
of dollars doing this
and it's something
that we continue to
be very committed to.
Another way that you can ingest
your data is offline ingest.
So we partner with Iron Mountain
in North America and Prime
Focus Technologies in
EMEA and in Asia-Pacific.
And you can actually
send them hard drives,
and they will upload those
files from the hard drives
into Google Cloud
Storage for you.
So if you don't feel
comfortable doing
all of that work
on your own, we're
working with
companies to make sure
that it's easy and secure for
you to upload those files.
Now, any talk about storage
wouldn't be complete
if we didn't talk
about our partnership
and our marketplace.
So Cloud Launcher is
where our partners
come to be able to launch
solutions into the Google Cloud
Platform.
I've highlighted
a number of them.
If what you really
need is Cassandra,
we've got a preconfigured
image through Bitnami,
one of our partners, to be able
to launch a Cassandra into GCE.
Same as EnterpriseDB.
Worked with EnterpriseDB to
get a solution up on GCE,
so that you can launch these
solutions into the cloud,
so that if we don't provide
a managed service that
meets your needs, you can
manage your own solution on GCE
with a single-click.
MongoDB is another example.
A lot of interest in MongoDB.
Make it very easy for
you to be able to spin up
those instances that
are running MongoDB
to support your workload.
Same thing with Redis.
A very popular caching solution.
So we make it one-click
possible to kick off
a VM that is a preconfigured
version of Redis.
That's all the concepts that
I wanted to cover today.
But the key takeaway
that I want to make
sure everyone
understands is that we
are striving to
make Google Cloud
Platform the place to store
your data in the public cloud.
We are faster, cheaper,
and more reliable
than many of the solutions
that are out there.
And then we're being fully
integrated to make sure
that we can actually
get your data,
move it, process
it, and enrich it,
and allow you to drive
value, whether that be
through BigQuery or running
machine learning models
on top of it, like the ones
that you saw at Sundar's keynote
yesterday.
Thank you, everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]